people very often say to me you know
you're anti-marriage i am not
anti-marriage
i know a lot of people who are happily
married not a lot
some some i will say all right one guy
the reason marriages fail is because of
women
no you're so desperate to get married
that you marry the wrong
person because it's not like guys are
begging to get married no
we're agreeing with the army exactly if
they're in the army maybe but we're
agreeing to marriage
yeah right because the woman wants it so
bad before y'all marry a good guy y'all
don't let him get no extracurricular
[ __ ]
because of what the media tells you yeah
you know what's not being manipulated by
the media the [ __ ] goes out and gets a
little [ __ ] on the side relax he's
coming home and he loves you and what
happens when he gets a little chlamydia
on the side he ain't going to get
nuclear
that's his fault first of all you could
clear that little gonorrhea on the side
he could clear that off
that's an antibiotic we'll just go get
some z-packs and it'll all be done
so what happens if he's out there
helping people uh and curing ebola what
happens with that
i don't know what that has to do with
anything but i'm just saying those worst
diseases he could get
doing good things there is no sex man i
had no idea that marriage just means
no sex no none [ __ ] none
i have friends that are thinking of
getting married and they say funny [ __ ]
like hey you know i don't know if i
could do it because i don't know if i
could have sex with one woman for the
rest of my life
like don't worry about that [ __ ]
you're gonna have sex with zero women
for the rest of your life
that's a lot less than one one woman who
the [ __ ] you think you are where'd you
get that fantasy
i'd love to have sex with one woman for
the rest of my life
any one woman big fat dead lady with a
beard i'd [ __ ] her every day
i'd be proud to have her
that's not usually my problem these days
my problem is very simple
it's trying to find a place in my house
where i can masturbate without somebody
bothering me
and that's really difficult
there's nowhere to go anymore she's got
her mother staying with us too in the
guest room
and i'm on the streets now i got nowhere
to go
like now i know when i see a guy in the
west side highway jerking off and
playing
daylight that's not a homeless guy
that's a married man right there
he's got nowhere to go [ __ ] it [ __ ] you
go ahead and look man i got no no what
else am i gonna do
it's not fair man i'm 37 and i own my
home i should be able to just stand in
the living room how you doing honey
good morning
[Applause]
but i can't i gotta hide i'm down in the
cellar by the boiler like a troll down
there
[Applause]
just [ __ ] miserable [ __ ]
that's what it's like masturbation
doesn't bring much joy to guys
women seem to like masturbating they put
flower petals on the pillow they're like
ah
me or whatever you know
[Applause]
my guys are looking at [ __ ] now if we're
gonna
damn it sometimes you find ecstasy but
it's followed by the deepest self-hating
depression you've ever felt it's an
amazing drop
from way up here to this like oh yeah
what the [ __ ] is wrong with me god damn
it
i gotta get to work i don't have time
for this [ __ ] right now
[Applause]
but then you get married now you gotta
hide and you have to
you have to hide because when your wife
catches you masturbating that that's
sad for the whole family that's not
not a good moment in a marriage
she comes in the cellar oh my god
and then she always wants to know [ __ ]
about it she always asks me stuff
my wife's like well do you think about
me when you're doing that
what are you [ __ ] high why would i do
that
what i can think about anybody that's
magical
why the [ __ ] would i i'm married to you
what do women really think their
husbands are going oh
my wife oh yeah that's [ __ ] hot
oh yeah picking her up at the airport
and getting yelled at oh that's [ __ ]
hot
yeah put it in the hamper not on top you
idiot oh i love when she talks like that
yeah
but uh you know whatever
we're a family we have a kid that
changes everything
that's the whole thing the kid is
everything marriage is nothing
without a kid marriage is dating it
doesn't mean [ __ ]
and you don't realize it till you have a
kid here's what happens when you get
married
you go holy [ __ ] i can't leave now i
mean i wasn't thinking of leaving but
now i really can't leave
then you have a kid and you go holy [ __ ]
i could have left
because i mean really what would life be
like if women acted like men
it would end life human life would come
to an end on earth because i mean faith
a guy would come to work at nine a.m
he'd see the first woman he'd go hey
let's do it right now and she'd go
sure i'm just like you we'll do it right
now and they would and the work would
get done no
food would be grown life would come to a
halt
that's why they had to invent marriage
so men would lose interest in sex and
get back to work
[Applause]
how cool is this murphy we're back for
another season season three dude
everybody's back this is awesome i'm
back i'm back
you're back ozil's back
somebody's missing though bro what what
do you mean someone's missing it looks
like one of them is missing who's
missing
uh the bass player will dog will dog
what happened to wild dog
he got married no are you kidding me
he got married this last weekend he just
got married dude we lost another one
how about a moment of silence ladies and
gentlemen a moment of silence for our
friend
wild dog you will be missed
we'll miss you well done it's it's only
appropriate we say a few words about
wild dog
you want to say a few things because you
know wild dog very well i know him well
but man come on you've hung out with him
he was a good guy
uh he lives behind a lot of uh undrunk
bottles of tequila
yeah he's behind the ability to dress
himself
he'll never be able to pick out an
outfit again bro never that's it he's
married
he's got he leaves behind the ability to
be himself
now he's gotta lie for the rest of his
life
that's bad not to mention the porn
collection he gave up
because he's a socio yeah he was a
suicide dirty dirty well dog
oh my god that is horrible ah
but why isn't he here i'm yeah he got
married this past weekend but how come
he's not here he's on his honeymoon in
aruba
oh look at him he's in an island
pretending to be happy
[Laughter]
why are you hating man i'm not happy
wouldn't you be happy if you were on
your honeymoon in aruba
no why not because i'd be happy because
i was in aruba it's like banging chicks
from
aruba that that are going to stay in
aruba
not with my wife
what would it be though come on man this
marriage is that bad bro it's pretty bad
bro it's like uh
you know nice he's in grace that guy
the married people are like oh yeah it's
pretty bad bro that's like uh that's
like uh
prison but without the sex
why do you know that nice no i'm just
saying
even the black guy's like damn right
[Applause]
you know one of the great things this
week um aside from seeing a bunch of
people that i've gone to high school
with people have been coming in and
you know i've been having them come
backstage and uh
like i said it's been awesome you know i
just been running to people and
everybody seems to be doing well
everybody's happy
seemed to be happily married i actually
ran into one of my friends who just got
divorced
within the last couple of years and i
got to tell you he was [ __ ] ecstatic
is there anything better as a guy than
meeting another guy that's happily
[ __ ] divorced
he's just [ __ ] loving life you know
he's got an apartment
couple two three boys you know he's like
oh dude it was time
it's he goes you know what i love about
it best he goes i'll be sitting in my
apartment there's a bar across the
street
and he goes i just think to myself wow
if i want to
i can just walk right over there
i can walk right in there and get a beer
you know
very simple thing so i know right there
a lot of women are probably thinking
like oh this guy was a bad husband he
was out there drinking all the time
you know there's always that [ __ ]
option but then there is the other
option
that you know sometimes ladies you know
you hold on to the reins a little too
tight you know what i mean you're kind
of yanking the head back and uh
you know if that horse wants to run
you're gonna have you're gonna have some
problems you know if you get some old
mayor that's going to go to the glue
factory he'll let you [ __ ] lead him
wherever the [ __ ] he wants you know
you married a stud right you got
yourself a million dollar horse there
you got to let that thing run every once
in a while
there you go ladies let me go off to the
pub and get a [ __ ] good buzz going
every once in a while
you know i know you're married i know
you got kids i know he comes home and he
[ __ ] mistakes the sink for the toilet
but every once in a while you know maybe
once a month
once a month you know that would be
[ __ ] amazing
all right let's just say you're in a
marriage right now and you know your
husband is a little
a little miserable you know and every
once in a while he needs to go out and
be frank the tank
what if you just let him get uber right
you get a pair of bomber socks
you get him an uber and say you know
what honey once every four to six weeks
you can go out with the fellas and just
get absolutely [ __ ]
loaded all right you come walking in
through the [ __ ] cellar doors we'll
have a couch down there you pass out the
next morning the kids won't know [ __ ]
all right just [ __ ] just blow out the
pipes
and then [ __ ] uh then you can come
home and then you know once every four
to six weeks
i get to go do whatever it is that women
do that they consider fun
i have no idea what you guys do what is
it that you guys do
you know i know women [ __ ] love women
love a glass of wine around four or five
o'clock
oh oh that is their cigar
huh guys you want your [ __ ] wife to
chill out
you know just [ __ ] pour a glass every
day around five o'clock
and she's [ __ ] moaning and complaining
at you just go shh
blah blah blah let us sit out right on
the back porch go ahead
you know she's in a really bad mood pour
another glass you'll be asleep by 6 30.
right then you go in with your kids what
do you do you throw in the [ __ ]
talking plane movie with dane cook as a
voice right get dan cook a little bit of
scratch
your kids are staring there you know you
[ __ ] poor whiskey that's that's what
parenting is all about
working with your partner so that the
two of you
can get a good buzz going every other
day without the kids noticing
and i know kids notice a lot but you
stick them in front of a tv they got no
idea what's going on
right there you go and you know
something i think that that's one to
grow on
you guys ever watched those did i talk
about this did you guys ever watch
i already talked about this and i don't
give a [ __ ] you guys got to go look up
uh
uh will forte's like greatest hits on uh
the snl site
just go on and just search will forte
you got to get those
those ones where they do the uh those
whole
um jesus bill spit it out well they do
the whole
spoof on that's one to grow on
well they got uh what's her face there
when she goes tapping tapping tapping on
my keyboard gotta get that report to my
balls
huh i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about anymore
all right hey ladies once every six
weeks
you know just let him go out and get
[ __ ] up
you know do him a solid and just say
listen i'm letting you get [ __ ] up but
you have to be [ __ ] husband of the
year for a week
is that cool be psyched be [ __ ]
psyched right
then all you guys got to do every once
in a while you pour a glass of wine and
then you're good
and then you're good and then your kids
grow up to be raging alcoholics and you
know what a family that drinks together
stays together all right you guys have a
lovely weekend
you have a great [ __ ] weekend you
[ __ ] i'll talk to you later